hi everybody hi drew i'm zoe francois
and i'm the author of zoe bakes cakes
and today i'm going to share one of my
favorite kitchen hacks with you that you
can use in your kitchen today i'm going
to show you how to use a kitchen scale
when i first started working in
professional kitchens it was the thing
that changed
everything about my baking and we had to
use a balanced scale now there's digital
scales they're super easy to use they're
super efficient they're much cleaner
than using cups and i'm going to show
you how to do it and i'm going to show
you why i like a digital scale i like a
one that has a nice wide platform so
that your bowl can sit on there
comfortably and you can see over it
they're little teeny tiny ones they work
but they're not as easy to use so get
yourself a nice big one then you're
going to want to just turn the scale on
since i turned it on with the bowl it's
going to read at zero even with the bowl
on it then i have to determine how much
flour i need so i'm going to my recipe
here i'm making my devil's food recipe
from my book 280 grams so i just go to
my flour
and i just fill the bowl up until i get
to 280 grams
[Music]
there we go 280.
because this recipe is all one single
bowl and everything is just stirred into
the same bowl i'm just going to add my
sugar right on top of my flour but in
order to do that i don't want to have to
add the numbers together so i'm just
going to zero out or tear the scale
now my scale is at zero again and now i
can add my sugar which is 400 grams so i
want 400 grams of sugar in here
now i need to add cocoa to my recipe so
i'm going to do the same thing what i
like to do for cocoa because sometimes
it can be lumpy any ingredient that's
lumpy i like to measure it or scale it
right into a sieve so that i can shake
out any lumps so i'm just gonna put my
sieve right on the bowl and then tear it
out or zero it so now we're at zero and
now i can add my cocoa powder so i need
50 grams
of cocoa powder
[Music]
and you can see
just how lumpy
that cocoa powder is and so i just
because i have it in the sieve
i can just
get all those lumps out and it's all
smooth so now all of my ingredients are
weighed out i've only dirtied one bowl
because that's the kind of recipe this
is it's a one bowl just dump it all in
and stir and that's it
if you don't have a scale
and you have to use measuring cups it's
okay you can do it i highly recommend
that you get a scale especially if you
like to bake a lot
but
there are different ways to measure
flour and so it's always a great idea to
go to the front of a cookbook and see
how the author does it does the author
[Music]
spoon and sweep which means that you
would spoon
the
flower right into the measuring cup just
like this
and so it's aerating the flour a little
bit you're gonna get a little bit less
flour this way so you're aerating the
flour
into the measuring cup and then
you just take a knife or a spatula and
sweep it
flat like that or does the author want
you to scoop and sweep which means that
you dip
the cup down into the flour and then
sweep it off
those two things
are going to get you a very different
amount of flour so it's really handy to
know how the author wrote the recipe the
scale takes all of the guesswork out so
get yourself a scale
make your baking easier make it more
consistent it's one of my absolute
favorite kitchen tools so if you get a
scale if you use this kitchen hack
please tag me at zoe bakes and use
hashtag
drewberrymoreshow on all social media so
that we can see what you're up to
and you can go to
thedrewberrymoreshow.com and get more
kitchen hacks and recipes and enjoy your
baking
[Music]
you